il avait été opéré en tunisie merci
sacha d'être avec nous vous avez suivi
donc une plénoplastie donc un
agrandissement du pénis
oui mais pas que d'accord oui mais c'est
bien de le dire oui vous avez aussi
corriger vos cernes
ça me semble hélas après l'intervention
a duré comme ça pendant une semaine
ces anneaux merci oui ça tombe bien je
suis végétarien vous êtes complexée
groupe lexsi vous avez corriger vos
servent vous avez fait une liposuccion
et donc augmenter la taille de vos
fesses exactement comment on fait pour
augmenter la taille de ses fesses qu'on
met une prothèse on fait comment non il
ya maintenant il ya d'autres recours que
les prothèses fait comment audi bref non
maintenant en fait on comprendre la
grèce ont la purifie et ensuite on l'a
réinjecte là où il ya déjà de l'ags
parfaite qui mangent pas osé alors donc
permis les caleçons maintenant j'assume
tout donc c'est pour ça que j'ai envoyé
cette photo
alors oui comme vous pouvez le voir sur
la première photo j'étais vraiment très
très complexée alors oui donc là c'est
vos fesses avons évoqué mais fait avant
on le voit pas la fin
moi je l'aurais pas mon mari net c'était
avant les maisons une invention oui on
est d'accord
et après ah ben ça c'est le cas c'est
l'évolution est donc donc vous avez un
générique donc de vous avez pris de la
grèce d'où en fait de géants fête j'ai
pris de la grèce 2
de medtech de ma ceinture abdominale les
emmys dans les faits ce même flanc et
j'ai mis dans mes fesses mais précise
mieux parce que comme vous pouvez le
voir j'avais vraiment rien et limite
c'est pas un mensonge ça me faisait même
mal quand je m'asseyais d'accord alors
jamais personne qui m'a pris au sérieux
ça me fait vraiment plaisir
maintenant vous a si vous êtes bien à
maintenant je suis très très heureux et
aujourd'hui je peux vraiment me regarde
dans le miroir et j'essaie de confiance
en moi et même avec les ça se ressent
peut demander à mes proches à se ressent
je me sens bien et vous avez donc fait
une ce qu'on appelle une plénoplastie
wec un agrandissement du pénis sur
combien de centimètres plus de questions
alors vous avez une question également
virginie comme ça on aura les deux
questions en même temps vous autant que
moi je serais censé largeur ou longueur
parce que sur la sueur l'aubergine on se
rend pas compte en fait c'est vrai alors
alors donc de combattre cm j'ai pas fait
agrandir j'ai fait élargir sa corps
derniers jours leur timide mais des
combats vous avez 10 2 cm et la
circonférence donc soit dans un certain
rayon air et de son trône en activité
combien les femmes je veux pas vous
montrer comme ça j'ai pas fait un
mauvais geste grossier d'accord voilà
vous allez fillon vous êtes économique
est celle du mouvement sur ce plateau
alors dont vous avez fait il a effectué
ses gros si oui mais pas grandir parce
que j'en avais pas besoin je ne vous
avais pas besoin de ça voilà à l'aller
ça c'est mon corps maintenant après mali
posé ma niveau est bon voilà on fait par
la quéquette dans le bon sens mais je
suis prêt vous étiez complet oui j'étais
très jeune ça vient jj très fin non en
fait bon j'aimerais revenir là dessus je
payais une grande polémique en fait bon
la vérité c'est qu'à la base je partais
faire une liposuccion parce que j'ai
j'étais obèses en étant plus jeune et
donc du coup même en ayant maigri je non
il faut pas rigoler tous les partis
faire une liposuccion
oui mais justement là je veux en venir
vous revenez avec 1
brody parce qu'en fait en tunisie dans
ce qu'on appelle un lip au feeling sait
on retire de la grèce et on peut la
réinjecter mais en fait ya passé dans le
14è donc vous êtes en train de me dire
vous étiez avec un chirurgien effet on
l'a de la glace c'est pas comme ça que
ça s'est passé en corse et quand j'ai
demandé où est ce qu'on pourrait
injecter en dehors de mes fesses parce
que c'était compris dans le port rob pas
d'accord global il m'a dit mais il ya
certaines personnes qui rajoute dans
l'essonne pour les camoufler donc vous
avez fait ça à grandir et les pecs parce
qu'ils sont ils ont eu un trou dans la
couche d'ozone a émis dans les cernes un
peu oui très bien dans les fesses
d'accord et du goodwill mahdi ben voila
voila on m'a dit s'il reste un peu de
graisse qu'est-ce qu'on en fait le reste
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
vraiment j'étais autant la gaspillent
est une marque comme la coupe pas on ne
la grandit chez un homme quelle femme ne
refuserai d'avoir déjà un peu plus beau
si on proposait à chaque fois passée une
caisse donc bien sûr oui oui mais
pourquoi la tunisie
pourquoi pas en france mais parce que
j'avais j'ai des camarades à moi de
juger des camarades un mois il est parti
avec un cigare à la main il est revenu
avec un bac route